[Music]
after leaving vienna
and long before you come to budapest the
danube enters a region of singular
loneliness and desolation
where its waters spread away on all
sides regardless of a main channel
and the country becomes a swamp for
miles upon miles
covered by a vast sea of low willow
bushes
on the big maps this deserted area is
painted in a fluffy blue
growing fainter in color as it leaves
the banks
and across it may be seen in large
straggling letters
the word zumfa meaning marshes
in high flood this great acreage of sand
shingle beds and willow-grown islands
is almost topped by the water but in
normal seasons the bushes bend and
rustle in the free winds
showing their silver leaves to the
sunshine and an ever-moving plane of
bewildering beauty
these willows never attain to the
dignity of trees
they have no rigid trunks they remain
humble bushes
with rounded tops and soft outline
swaying on slender stems that answer to
the least pressure of the wind
supple as grasses and so continually
shifting that they somehow give the
impression that the entire plane is
moving
and alive for the wind sends waves
rising and falling over the whole
surface
waves of leaves instead of waves of
water green swells like the sea
too until the branches turn and lift and
then silvery white
as their underside turns to the sun
happy to slip beyond the control of the
stern banks
the danube pier wanders about at will
among the intricate network of channels
intersecting the islands everywhere with
broad avenues
down which the waters poor with a
shouting sound
making whirlpools eddies and foaming
rapids
tearing at the sandy banks carrying away
masses of shore and willow clumps
and forming new islands innumerably
which shift daily in size and shape
and possess at best an impermanent life
since the flood time obliterates their
very existence
properly speaking this fascinating part
of the river's life begins
soon after leaving pressburg and we in
our canadian canoe
with gypsy tent and frying pan on board
reached it on the crest of a rising
flood about mid-july
that very same morning when the sky was
reddening before
sunrise we had slipped swiftly through
still-sleeping vienna
leaving it a couple of hours later a
mere patch of smoke against the blue
hills of the wienerwald on the horizon
we had breakfasted below fisher almond
under a grove of birch trees roaring in
the wind
and it then swept on the tearing current
past earth
hainburg petronel the old roman
carnuntum of marcus aurelius
and so under the frowning heights of
felson on a spur of the carpathians
where the march steals in quietly from
the left and the frontier is crossed
between austria and hungary
racing along at 12 kilometers an hour
soon took us well into hungary
and the muddy waters sure sign of flood
sent us a ground on many a shingle bed
and twisted us like a cork and many a
sudden belching whirlpool
before the towers of pressburg hungarian
pogeny
showed against the sky and then the
canoe
leaping like a spirited horse flew at
top speed under the gray walls
negotiated safely the sunken chain of
the fleegan de brooka fairy
turned the corner sharply to the left
and plunged on yellow foam into the
wilderness of islands
sandbanks and swampland beyond the land
of the willows
the change came suddenly as when a
series of bioscope pictures snaps down
on the streets of a town
and shifts without warning into the
scenery of lake and forest
we entered the land of desolation on
wings and in less than half an hour
there was neither boat nor a fishing hut
nor red roof
nor any single sign of human habitation
and civilization within sight
the sense of remoteness from the world
of humankind
the utter isolation the fascination of
this singular world of willows
winds and waters instantly laid its
spell upon us both
so that we allowed laughingly to one
another that we ought by
rights to have held some special kind of
passport to admit us
and that we had somewhat audaciously
come without asking leave into a
separate little kingdom of wonder and
magic
a kingdom that was reserved for the use
of others who had a right to
it and everywhere unwritten warnings to
trespassers for those who had the
imagination to discover them
though still early in the afternoon the
ceaseless buffetings of a most
tempestuous wind made us feel weary
and we at once began casting about for a
suitable camping ground for the night
but the bewildering character of the
islands made landing difficult
the swirling flood carried us in shore
and then swept us out again
the willow branches tore our hands as we
seized them to stop the canoe
and we pulled many a yard of sandy bank
into the water
before at length we shot with a great
sideways blow from the wind
into a backwater and managed to beach
the boughs in a cloud of spray
then we lay panting and laughing after
our exertions on the hot yellow sand
sheltered from the wind and in the full
blaze of a scorching sun
a cloudless blue sky above and an
immense army of dancing
shouting willow bushes closing in from
all sides
shining with spray and clapping their
thousand little hands
as though to applaud the success of our
efforts
what a river i said to my companion
thinking of all the way we had traveled
from the source in the black forest
and how he had often been obliged to
wade and push in the upper shallows at
the beginning of june
won't stand much nonsense now will it he
said
pulling the canoe a little farther into
safety up the sand
and then composing himself for a nap
i lay by his side happy and peaceful in
the bath of the elements
water wind sand and the great fire of
the sun
thinking of the long journey that lay
behind us and of the great stretch
before us to the black sea
and how lucky i was to have such a
delightful and charming traveling
companion
as my friend the swede we had made many
similar journeys together
but the danube more than any other river
i knew
impressed us from the very beginning
with its aliveness
from its tiny bubbling entry into the
world among the pinewood gardens of dana
eschingen
until this moment when it began to play
the great river game of losing itself
among the deserted swamps
unobserved unrestrained it had seemed to
us like following the groan of some
living creature
sleepy at first but later developing
violent desires as it became conscious
of its deep soul
it rolled like some huge fluid being
through all the countries we had passed
holding our little craft on its mighty
shoulders playing roughly with us
sometimes
yet always friendly and well-meaning
till at length we had come inevitably to
regard it as a great personage
how indeed could it be otherwise since
it told us so much of its secret life
at night we heard it singing to the moon
as we lay in our tent
uttering that odd sibilant note peculiar
to itself
and said to be caused by the rapid
tearing of the pebbles along its bed
so great is its hurrying speed we knew
too
the voice of its gurgling whirlpools
suddenly bubbling up on a surface
previously quite calm the roar of its
shallows and swift rapids
its constant steady thundering below all
mere surface
sounds and that ceaseless tearing of its
icy waters at the bank
how it stood up and shouted when the
rains fell flat upon its face
and how its laughter roared out when the
wind blew upstream
and tried to stop its growing speed we
knew
all its sounds and voices its tumblings
and foamings
its unnecessary splashing against the
bridges
that self-conscious chatter when there
were hills to look on
the affected dignity of its speech when
it passed through the little towns
far too important to laugh and all these
faint sweet whisperings when the sun
caught it fairly in some slow curve
and poured down upon it till the steam
rose
it was full of tricks too in its early
life before the great world knew it
there were places in the upper reaches
among the swabian forests
when yet the first whispers of its
destiny had not reached it
where it elected to disappear through
holes in the ground
to appear again on the other side of the
porous limestone hills
and start a new river with another name
leaving
too so little water in its own bed that
we had to climb out and wade and push
the canoe through miles of shallows
and a chief pleasure in those early days
of its irresponsible youth
was to lie low like braer fox just
before the little turbulent tributaries
came to join it from the alps
and to refuse to acknowledge them went
in but to run for miles side by side
the dividing line well marked the very
level is different
the danube utterly declining to
recognize the newcomer
below passow however it gave up this
particular trick
for there the inn comes in with a
thundering power impossible to ignore
and so pushes and incommodes the parent
river that there is hardly room for them
in the long twisting gorge that follows
and the danube is shoved this way in
that against the cliffs
and forced to hurry itself with great
waves and much dashing to and fro
in order to get through in time and
during the fight our
canoe slipped down from its shoulder to
its breast and had the time of its life
among the struggling waves
but the inn taught the old river a
lesson and after passau
it no longer pretended to ignore new
arrivals
this was many days back of course and
since then we had come to know other
aspects of the great creature
and across the bavarian wheat plain of
straubing she wandered so
slowly under the blazing june sun that
we could well imagine only the surface
inches were water
while below they're moved concealed as
by a silken mantle
a whole army of undines passing silently
and
unseen down to the sea and very
leisurely too
lest they be discovered much too
we forgave her because of her
friendliness to the birds and animals
that haunted the shores
cormorants lined the banks in lonely
places in rows like short black palings
gray crows crowded the shingle beds
storks stood fishing in the vistas of
shallower water that opened up between
the islands
and hawks swans and marsh birds of all
sorts
filled the air with glinting wings and
singing petulant cries
it was impossible to feel annoyed with
the river's vagaries
after seeing a deer leap with a splash
into the water at sunrise
and swim past the boughs of the canoe
and often we saw fawns peering at us
from the underbrush
or looked straight into the brown eyes
of a stag as we charged full tilt round
a corner
and entered another reach of the river
foxes too
everywhere haunted the banks tripping
daintily among the driftwood and
disappearing so
suddenly that it was impossible to see
how they managed it
but now after leaving pressburg
everything changed a little
and the danube became more serious it
ceased trifling
it was halfway to the black sea within
seeming distance almost of other
stranger countries
where no tricks would be permitted or
understood
it became suddenly grown up and claimed
our respect
and even our awe it broke out into three
arms for one thing
that only met again 100 kilometers
farther down
and for a canoe there were no
indications which one was intended to be
followed
if you take a side channel said the
hungarian officer we met in the
pressburg shop while buying provisions
you may find yourselves when the flood
subsides 40 miles from anywhere
high and dry and you may easily starve
there are no people no farms no
fishermen
i warn you not to continue the river too
is still rising and this wind will
increase
the rising river did not alarm us in the
least but the matter of being left high
and dry by a sudden subsidence of the
waters might be serious
and we had consequently laid in an extra
stock of provisions
for the rest the officer's prophecy held
true
and the wind blowing down a perfectly
clear sky
increased steadily till it reached the
dignity of a westerly gale
it was earlier than usual when we camped
for the sun was a good hour or two from
the horizon
and leaving my friends still asleep on
the hot sand i wandered about in
desultery examination of our hotel
the island i found was less than an acre
in extent
a mere sandy bank standing some two or
three feet above the level of the river
the far end pointing into the sunset was
covered with flying spray
which the tremendous wind drove off the
crests of the broken waves
it was triangular in shape with the apex
upstream
i stood there for several minutes
watching the impetuous crimson flood
bearing down with a shouting roar
dashing in waves against the bank as
though to sweep it bodily away
and then swirling by and two foaming
streams on either side
the ground seemed to shake with the
shock and rush while the furious
movement of the willow bushes as the
wind poured over them
increased the curious illusion that the
island itself actually moved
above for a mile or two i could see the
great river descending upon me
it was like looking up the slope of a
sliding hill white with foam
and leaping up everywhere to show itself
to the sun
the rest of the island was too thickly
grown with willows to make walking
pleasant
but i made the tour nevertheless from
the lower end the light of course
changed and the river looked dark and
angry
only the backs of the flying waves were
visible streaked with foam
and pushed forcibly by the great puffs
of wind that fell upon them from behind
for a short mile it was visible pouring
in and out among the islands
and then disappearing with a huge sweep
into the willows
which closed about it like a herd of
monstrous antediluvian creatures
crowding down to drink
they made me think of gigantic
sponge-like growths
that sucked the river up into themselves
they caused it to vanish from sight
they herded there together in such
overpowering numbers
altogether it was an impressive scene
with its utter loneliness
its bizarre suggestion and as i gazed
long and curiously a singular emotion
began to stir
somewhere in the depths of me midway in
my delight of the wild beauty
their crept unbidden and unexplained
a curious feeling of disquietude almost
of alarm
a rising river perhaps always suggests
something of the ominous
many of the little islands i saw before
me would probably have been swept away
by the morning
this resistless thundering flood of
water touched the sense of awe
yet i was aware that my uneasiness lay
deeper far than the emotions of awe and
wonder
it was not that i felt nor had it
directly to do with the power of the
driving wind
the shouting hurricane that might almost
carry up a few acres of willows into the
air
and scatter them like so much chaff over
the landscape
the wind was simply enjoying itself for
nothing rose out of the flat landscape
to stop it
and i was conscious of sharing its great
game with a kind of pleasurable
excitement
yet this novel emotion had nothing to do
with the wind
indeed so vague was the sense of
distress i experienced
that it was impossible to trace it to
its source and deal with it accordingly
though i was aware somehow that it had
to do with my realization of our utter
insignificance
before this unrestrained power of the
elements about me
the huge grown river had something to do
with it too
a vague unpleasant idea that we had
somehow trifled with these great
elemental forces
in whose power we lay helpless every
hour of the day and night
for here indeed they were gigantically
at play together
and the sight appealed to the
imagination
but my emotion so far as i could
understand it
seemed to attach itself more
particularly to the willow bushes
to these acres and acres of willows
crowding
so thickly growing there swarming
everywhere the eye could reach
pressing upon the river as though to
suffocate it standing in dense array
mile after mile beneath the sky watching
waiting listening and apart quite from
the elements
the willows connected themselves subtly
with my malays
attacking the mind insidiously somehow
by reason of their vast numbers
and contriving in some way or other to
represent to the imagination a new and
mighty power
a power moreover not altogether friendly
to us
great revelations of nature of course
never failed to impress in one way or
another
and i was no stranger to moods of the
kind
mountains overall and oceans terrify
while the mystery of great forests
exercises a spell peculiarly its own
but all these at one point or another
somewhere link on
intimately with human life and human
experience
they stir comprehensible even if
alarming emotions
they tend on the whole to exalt
with this multitude of willows however
it was something far
different i felt some essence emanated
from them that besieged the heart
a sense of awe awakened true but of awe
touched somewhere by a vague terror
their seried ranks growing everywhere
darker about me as the shadows deepened
moving furiously yet softly in the wind
woke in me the curious and unwelcome
suggestion
that we had trespassed here upon the
borders of an alien world
a world where we were intruders a world
where we were not wanted
or invited to remain where we ran grave
risks perhaps
the feeling however though it refused to
yield its meaning entirely to analysis
did not at the time trouble me by
passing into menace
yet it never left me quite even during
the very practical business of putting
up the tent in a hurricane of wind
and building a fire for the stewpot it
remained
just enough to bother and perplex and to
rob a most delightful camping ground of
a good portion of its charm
to my companion however i said nothing
for he was a man i considered devoid of
imagination
in the first place i could never have
explained to him what i meant
and in the second he would have laughed
stupidly at me if i had
there was a slight depression in the
center of the island and here we pitched
the tent
the surrounding willows broke the wind a
bit
a poor camp observed the imperturbal
swede when at last the tent stood
upright
no stones and precious little firewood
i'm from moving on early tomorrow a
the sand won't hold anything but the
experience of a collapsing tent at
midnight had taught us many devices
and we made the cozy gypsy house as safe
as possible
and then set about collecting a store of
wood to last till bedtime
willow bushes dropped no branches and
driftwood was our only source of supply
we hunted the shores pretty thoroughly
everywhere the banks were crumbling
as the rising flood tore at them and
carried away great portions with a
splash and a gurgle
the island's much smaller than when we
landed said the accurate swede
it won't last long at this rate we
better drag the canoe close to the tent
and be ready to start at a moment's
notice i shall sleep in my clothes
he was a little distance off climbing
along the bank and i heard his rather
jolly laugh as he spoke
by jove i heard him call a moment later
and turn to see what had caused his
exclamation
but for the moment he was hidden by the
willows and i could not find him
what in the world's this i heard him cry
again and this time his voice had
become serious i ran up quickly and
joined him on the bank
he was looking over the river pointing
at something in the water
good heavens it's a man's body he cried
excitedly
look a black thing turning over and over
in the foaming waves
swept rapidly past it kept disappearing
and coming up to the surface again
it was about 20 feet from the shore and
just as it was opposite to where we
stood
it lurched round and looked straight at
us
we saw its eyes reflecting the sunset
and gleaming an odd yellow as the body
turned over
then it gave a swift gulping plunge and
dived out of sight in a flash
an otter by gad we exclaimed in the same
breath
laughing it was an otter
alive and out on the hunt yet it had
looked exactly like the body of a
drowned man
turning helplessly in the current far
below it came to the surface once again
and we saw its black skin wet and
shining in the sunlight
then too just as we turned back our arms
full of driftwood
another thing happened to recall us to
the riverbank
this time it really was a man and what
was more a man in a boat
now a small boat on the danube was an
unusual sight at any time
but here in this deserted region and at
flood time it was so unexpected
as to constitute a real event we stood
and stared
whether it was due to the slanting
sunlight or the refraction from the
wonderfully illuminated water
i cannot say but whatever the cause i
found it difficult to focus my
sight properly upon the flying
apparition it seemed however to be a man
standing upright in a sort of
flat-bottomed boat
steering with a long oar and being
carried down the opposite shore at a
tremendous pace
he apparently was looking across in our
direction but the distance was too great
and the light too uncertain
for us to make out very plainly what he
was about
it seemed to me that he was
gesticulating and making signs at us
his voice came across the water to us
shouting something furiously
but the wind drowned it so that no
single word was audible
there was something curious about the
whole appearance man
boat signs voice that made an impression
on me out of all proportion to its cause
he's crossing himself i cried look he's
making the sign of the cross
i believe you're right the swede said
shading his eyes with his hand
and watching the man out of sight he
seemed to be gone in a moment
melting away down there into the sea of
willows where the sun caught them in the
bend of the river
and turned them into a great crimson
wall of beauty
mist too had begun to rise so that the
air was hazy
but what in the world is he doing at
nightfall on this flooded river
i said half to myself where is he going
at such a time
and what did he mean by his signs and
shouting do you think he wished to warn
us about something
he saw our smoke and thought we were
spirits probably
left my companion these hungarians
believe in all sorts of rubbish
you remember the shop woman at pressburg
warning us that no one ever landed here
because it belonged to some sort of
beings outside
man's world i suppose they believe in
fairies and elementals
possibly demons too that peasant in the
boat saw people on the islands for the
first time in his life
he added after a slight pause and it
scared him
that's all the swede's tone of voice was
not convincing
and his manner lacked something that was
usually there
i noted the change instantly while he
talked though without being able to
label it precisely
if they had enough imagination i laughed
loudly
i remember trying to make as much noise
as i could they might well people a
place like this with the old gods of
antiquity
the romans must have haunted all this
region more or less with their shrines
and sacred groves
and elemental deities the subject
dropped and we returned to our stewpot
for my friend was not given to
imaginative conversation as a rule
moreover just then i remember feeling
distinctly glad that he was not
imaginative
his solid practical nature suddenly
seemed to me welcome and comforting
it was an admirable temperament i felt
he could steer down rapids like a red
indian
shoot dangerous bridges in whirlpools
better than any white man i ever saw in
a canoe
he was a grand fellow for an adventurous
trip a tower of strength when untoward
things happened
i looked at his strong face and light
curly hair as he staggered along under
his pile of driftwood
twice the size of mine and i experienced
a feeling of relief
yes i was distinctly glad just then that
the swede was
what he was and that he never made
remarks that suggested more than they
said
the river's still rising though he added
as if following out some thoughts of his
own
and dropping his load with a gasp this
island will be underwater in two days if
it goes on
i wish the wind would go down i said i
don't care a fig for the river
the flood indeed had no terrors for us
we could get off at 10 minutes notice
and the more water the better we liked
it it meant an increasing current
and the obliteration of the treacherous
shingle beds that so often threatened to
tear the bottom out of our canoe
contrary to our expectations the wind
did not go down with the sun
it seemed to increase with the darkness
howling overhead and shaking the willows
around us like straws
curious sounds accompanied it sometimes
like the explosion of heavy guns
and it fell upon the water and the
island in great flat blows of immense
power
it made me think of the sounds a planet
must make could we only hear it
driving along through space
but the sky kept wholly clear of clouds
and soon after supper the full moon rose
up in the east
and covered the river in the plain of
shouting willows with a light like the
day
we lay on the sandy patch beside the
fire smoking
listening to the noises of the night
round us and talking happily of the
journey we had already made
and of our plans ahead the map lay
spread in the door of the tent
but the high wind made it hard to study
and presently we lowered the curtain and
extinguished the lantern
the fire light was enough to smoke and
see each other's faces by
and the sparks flew about overhead like
fireworks
a few yards beyond the river gurgled and
hissed
and from time to time a heavy splash
announced the falling away of further
portions of the bank
our talk i noticed had to do with the
far away scenes and incidents of our
first camps in the black forest
or of other subjects altogether remote
from the present setting
for neither of us spoke of the actual
moment more than was necessary
almost as though we had agreed tacitly
to avoid discussion of the camp and its
incidents
neither the otter nor the boatmen for
instance received the honor of a single
mention
though ordinarily these would have
furnished discussion for the greater
part of the evening
they were of course distinct events in
such a place
the scarcity of wood made it a business
to keep the fire going
for the wind that drove the smoke in our
faces wherever we sat
helped at the same time to make a forced
draft
we took it in turn to make some foraging
expeditions into the darkness
and the quantity the swede brought back
always made me feel that he took an
absurdly long time finding it
for the fact was i did not care much
about being left alone
and yet it always seemed to be my turn
to grub about among the bushes or
scramble along the slippery banks in the
moonlight
the long day's battle with wind and
water such wind and water
had tired us both and an early bed was
the obvious program
yet neither of us made the move for the
tent we lay there
tending the fire talking in desultery
fashion
peering about us into the dense willow
bushes and listening to the thunder of
wind and river
the loneliness of the place had entered
our very bones
and silence seemed natural for after a
bit the sound of our voices became a
trifle unreal and forced
whispering would have been the fitting
mode of communication i felt
and the human voice always rather absurd
amid the roar of the elements
now carried with it something almost
illegitimate
it was like talking out loud in church
or in some place where it was not lawful
perhaps not quite safe to be overheard
the eeriness of this lonely island said
among a million willows
swept by a hurricane and surrounded by
hurrying deep waters
touched as both i fancy untrodden by man
almost unknown to man it lay there
beneath the moon
remote from human influence on the
frontier of another world
an alien world a world tenanted by
willows only and the souls of willows
and we in our rashness had dared to
invade it even to make use of it
something more than the power of its
mystery stirred in me as i lay on the
sand
feet to fire and peered up through the
leaves at the stars
for the last time i rose to get firewood
when this is burnt up i said firmly i
shall turn in
and my companion watched me lazily as i
moved off into the surrounding shadows
for an unimaginative man i thought he
seemed unusually receptive that night
unusually open to suggestion of things
other than sensory
he too was touched by the beauty and
loneliness of the place
i was not altogether pleased i remember
to recognize this slight change in him
and instead of immediately collecting
sticks i made my way to the far
point of the island where the moonlight
on plane and river could be seen to
better advantage
the desire to be alone had come suddenly
upon me
my former dread returned in force there
was a vague feeling in me i wish to face
and probe to the bottom
when i reached the point of sand jutting
out among the waves
the spell of the place descended upon me
with a positive shock
no mere scenery could have produced such
an effect
there was something more here something
to alarm
i gazed across the waist of wild waters
i watched the whispering willows
i heard the ceaseless beating of the
tireless wind
and one and all each in its own way
stirred in me this sensation of a
strange distress
but the willows especially forever they
went on
chattering and talking among themselves
laughing a little
shrilly crying out sometimes sighing
but what it was they made so much to do
about belonged to the secret life of the
great plain they inhabited
and it was utterly alien to the world i
knew or to that of the wild yet kindly
elements
they made me think of a host of beings
from another plane of life
another evolution altogether perhaps all
discussing a mystery known only to
themselves
i watched them moving busily together
oddly shaking their big bushy heads
twirling their myriad leaves even when
there was no wind
they moved of their own will as though
alive and they touched by some
incalculable method my own keen sense of
the horrible
there they stood in the moonlight like a
vast army surrounding our
camp shaking their innumerable silver
spears defiantly
formed already for an attack
the psychology of places for some
imaginations at least
is very vivid for the wanderer
especially
camps have their note either of welcome
or rejection
at first it may not always be apparent
because the busy preparations of tent
and cooking prevent
but with the first pause after supper
usually
it comes and announces itself and the
note of this willow camp
now became unmistakably plain to me we
were interlopers
trespassers we were not welcomed
the sense of unfamiliarity grew upon me
as i stood there watching
we touched the frontier of a region
where our presence was
resented for a night's lodging we might
perhaps be tolerated
but for a prolonged and inquisitive stay
no
by all the gods of the trees and
wilderness no
we were the first human influences upon
this island and we were not wanted
the willows were against us
strange thoughts like these bizarre
fancies
born i know not once found lodgement in
my mind as i stood listening
what i thought if after all these
crouching willows prove to be alive
if suddenly they should rise up like a
swarm of living
creatures marshalled by the gods whose
territory we had invaded
sweep towards us off the vast swamps
booming overhead in the night
and then settle down as i looked it was
so easy to imagine they actually moved
crept nearer retreated a little huddled
together in masses
hostile waiting for the great wind that
should finally start them or running
i could have sworn their aspect changed
a little and their ranks deepened and
pressed more closely together
the melancholy shrill cry of a night
bird sounded overhead
and suddenly i nearly lost my balance as
the piece of bank i stood upon
fell with a great splash into the river
undermined by the flood
i stepped back just in time and went on
hunting for firewood again
half laughing at the odd fancies that
crowded so thickly into my mind and cast
their spell upon me
i recalled the swede's remark about
moving on next day
and i was just thinking that i fully
agreed with him when i turned with a
start and saw the subject of my thoughts
standing immediately in front of me
he was quite close the roar of the
elements had covered his approach
you've been gone so long he shouted
above the wind
i thought something must have happened
to you
but there was that in its tone and a
certain look in his face as well
that conveyed to me more than his usual
words and in a flash i understood the
real reason for his coming
it was because the spell of the place
had entered his soul too
and he did not like being alone river
still rising
he cried pointing to the flood in the
moonlight and the wind simply awful
he always said the same things but it
was the cry for companionship
that gave the real importance to his
words
lucky i cried back our tents in the
hollow
i think it'll hold all right i added
something about the difficulty of
finding wood
in order to explain my absence but the
wind caught my words and flung them
across the river
so that he did not hear but just looked
at me through the branches
nodding his head lucky if we get away
without disaster
he shouted or words to that effect and i
remember feeling half angry with him for
putting the thought into words
for it was exactly what i felt myself
there was disaster impending somewhere
and the sense of pre-sentiment lay
unpleasantly upon me
we went back to the fire and made a
final blaze poking it up with our feet
we took a last look round but for the
wind the heat would have been unpleasant
i put this thought into words and i
remember my friend's reply
struck me oddly that he would rather
have the heat the ordinary july weather
than this diabolical wind everything was
snug for the night
the canoe lying turned over beside the
tent with both yellow paddles beneath
her
the provision sack hanging from a willow
stem and the washed-up dishes removed to
a safe distance from the fire
all ready for the morning meal we
smothered the embers of the fire with
sand
and then turned in the flap of the tent
door was up
and i saw the branches and the stars and
the white moonlight
the shaking willows and the heavy
buffetings of the wind against our taut
little house
where the last things i remembered as
sleep came down
and covered all with its soft and
delicious forgetfulness
suddenly i found myself lying awake
peering from my sandy mattress through
the door of the tent
i looked at my watch pinned against the
canvas and saw by the bright moonlight
that it was past 12 o'clock
the threshold of a new day and i had
therefore slept a couple of hours
the swede was asleep still beside me the
wind howled as before
something plucked at my heart and made
me feel afraid
there was a sense of disturbance in my
immediate neighborhood
i sat up quickly and looked out the
trees were swaying violently to and fro
as the gusts smote them
but our little bit of green canvas lay
snugly safe in the hollow
for the wind passed over it without
meeting enough resistance to make it
vicious
the feeling of disquiet did not pass
however and i crawled quietly out of the
tent to see if our belongings were safe
i moved carefully so as not to waken my
companion
a curious excitement was on me i was
halfway out
kneeling on all fours when my eye first
took in that the tops of the bush's
opposite with their moving tracery of
leaves
made shapes against the sky i sat back
on my haunches and stared
it was incredible surely but there
opposite and slightly above me
were shapes of some indeterminate sword
among the willows
and as the branches swayed in the wind
they seemed to group themselves about
these shapes
forming a series of monstrous outlines
that shifted rapidly beneath the moon
close about 50 feet in front of me i saw
these things
my first instinct was to waken my
companion that he too might see them
but something made me hesitate the
sudden realization
probably that i should not welcome
corroboration
and meanwhile i crouched there staring
in amazement with smarting eyes
i was wide awake i remember saying to
myself that i was not dreaming
they first became properly visible these
huge figures
just within the tops of the bushes
immense bronze colored
moving and wholly independent of the
swaying of the branches
i saw them plainly and noted now i came
to examine them more calmly
that they were very much larger than
human and indeed that something in their
appearance proclaimed them to be not
human at all
certainly they were not merely the
moving tracery of the branches against
the moonlight
they shifted independently they rose
upwards in a continuous stream from
earth to
sky vanishing utterly as soon as they
reach the dark of the sky
they were interlaced one with another
making a great column
and i saw their limbs and huge bodies
melting in and out of each other
forming this serpentine line that bent
and swayed and twisted spirally with the
contortions of the wind-tossed trees
they were nude fluid shapes passing up
the bushes within the leaves almost
rising up in a living column into the
heavens their faces i could never see
unceasingly they poured upwards swaying
in great bending curves
with a hue of dull bronze upon their
skins
i stared trying to force every atom of
vision from my
eyes for a long time i thought they must
every moment disappear and resolve
themselves into the movements of the
branches and proved to be an optical
illusion
i searched everywhere for a proof of
reality when all the while i understood
quite well that the standard of reality
had changed
for the longer i looked the more certain
i became that these figures were real
and living
though perhaps not according to the
standards that the camera and the
biologist would insist upon
far from feeling fear i was possessed
with a sense of awe and wonder
such as i have never known i seemed to
be gazing at the personified elemental
forces of this haunted and primeval
region
our intrusion had stirred the powers of
the place into activity
it was we who were the cause of the
disturbance and my brain filled to
bursting with stories and legends of the
spirits and deities of places that have
been acknowledged and worshiped by men
in all ages of the world's history
but before i could arrive at any
possible explanation
something impelled me to go farther out
and i crept forward on the sand and
stood upright
i felt the ground still warm under my
bare feet
the wind tore at my hair and face and
the sound of the river burst upon my
ears with a sudden roar
these things i knew were real and proved
that my senses were acting normally
yet the figures still rose from earth to
heaven
silent majestically in a great spiral of
grace and strength
that overwhelmed me at length with a
genuine deep emotion of worship
i felt that i must fall down in worship
absolutely worship
perhaps in another minute i might have
done so when a gust of wind swept
against me with such force that it blew
me sideways
and i nearly stumbled and fell it seemed
to shake the dream
violently out of me at least it gave me
another point of view somehow
the figures still remained still
ascended into heaven from the heart of
the night
but my reason at last began to assert
itself
it must be a subjective experience i
argued
nonetheless real for that but still
subjective
the moonlight and the branches combined
to work out these pictures upon the
mirror of my imagination
and for some reason i projected them
outwards and made them appear
objective i knew this must be the case
of course
i took courage and began to move forward
across the open patches of sand
by jove though was it all hallucination
was it merely subjective
did not my reason argue in the old
futile way from the little standard of
the known
i only know that great column of figures
ascended darkly into the sky for what
seemed a very long period of time
and with a very complete measure of
reality as most men are accustomed to
gauge reality
then suddenly they were gone and once
they were gone
and the immediate wonder of their great
presence had passed
fear came down upon me with a cold rush
the esoteric meaning of this lonely and
haunted region suddenly flamed up within
me
and i began to tremble dreadfully i took
a quick look round
a look of horror that came near to panic
calculating vainly ways of escape
and then realizing how helpless i was to
achieve anything really effective
i crept back silently into the tent and
lay down again
upon my sandy mattress first lowering
the door curtain to shut out the sight
of the willows in the moonlight
and then burying my head as deeply as
possible beneath the blankets
to deaden the sound of the terrifying
wind
as though further to convince me that i
had not been dreaming
i remember that it was a long time
before i fell again into a troubled and
restless sleep
and even then only the upper crust of me
slept and underneath
it was something that never quite lost
consciousness but lay alert and on the
watch
but this second time i jumped up with a
genuine start of terror
it was neither the wind nor the river
that woke me but the slow approach of
something that caused the sleeping
portion of me to grow smaller and
smaller
till at last it vanished altogether and
i found myself sitting bolt upright
listening outside there was a sound of
multitudinous little patterns
they had been coming i was aware for a
long time and in my sleep they had first
become audible
i sat there nervously wide awake as
though i had not slept at all
it seemed to me that my breathing came
with difficulty and that there was a
great weight upon the surface of my body
in spite of the hot night i felt clammy
with cold and shivered
something surely was pressing steadily
against the sides of the tent
and weighing down upon it from above was
it the body of the wind
was this the patterning rain the
dripping of the leaves the spray blown
from the river by the wind and gathering
in big drops
i thought quickly of a dozen things then
suddenly the explanation leaped into my
mind
a bow from the poplar the only large
tree on the island
had fallen with the wind still half
caught by the other branches
it would fall with a next gush and crush
us and meanwhile its leaves brushed and
tapped upon the tight canvas surface of
the tent
i raised a loose flap and rushed out
calling to the swede to follow
but when i got out and stood upright i
saw that the tent was free
there was no hanging bow there was no
rain or spray nothing approached
a cold gray light filtered down through
the bushes and lay on the faintly
gleaming sand
stars still crowded the sky directly
overhead
and the wind howled magnificently but
the fire no longer gave
out any glow and i saw the east
reddening in streaks through the trees
several hours must have passed since i
stood there before watching the
ascending figures
and the memory of it now came back to me
horribly like an evil dream oh how tired
it made me feel
that ceaseless raging wind yet though
the deep lassitude of a sleepless night
was on me
my nerves were tingling with the
activity of an equally tireless
apprehension
and all idea of repose was out of the
question
the river i saw had risen further its
thunder filled the air
and a fine spray made itself felt
through my thin sleeping shirt
yet nowhere did i discover the slightest
evidence of anything to cause alarm
this deep prolonged disturbance in my
heart remained wholly unaccounted for
my companion had not stirred when i
called him and there was no need to
waken him now
i looked about me carefully noting
everything
the turned over canoe the yellow paddles
two of them i'm certain
the provision sack and the extra lantern
hanging together from the tree
and crowding everywhere about me
enveloping all the willows
those endless shaking willows a bird
uttered its morning cry
and a string of duck past with whirring
flight overhead in the twilight
the sand whirled dry and stinging about
my bare feet in the wind
i walked round the tent and then went
out a little way into the bush
so that i could see across the river to
the farther landscape
and the same profound yet indefinable
emotion of distress
seized upon me again as i saw the
interminable sea of bushes stretching
to the horizon looking ghostly and
unreal in the one light of dawn
i walked softly here and there still
puzzling over that odd sound of infinite
patterning
and of that pressure upon the tent that
had wakened me
it must have been the wind i reflected
the wind bearing upon the loose hot sand
driving the dry particles smartly
against the taut canvas
the wind dropping heavily upon our
fragile roof
yet all the time my nervousness and
malaise increased appreciably
i crossed over to the farther shore and
noted how the coastline had altered in
the night
and what masses of sand the river had
torn away
i dipped my hands and feet into the cool
current and bathed my forehead
already there was a glow of sunrise in
the sky and the exquisite freshness of a
coming day
on my way back i passed purposely
beneath the very bushes where i had seen
the column of figures rising into the
air
and midway among the clumps i suddenly
found myself overtaken by a sense of
vast terror
from the shadows a large figure went
swiftly by
someone passed me as sure as ever man
did
it was a great staggering blow from the
wind that helped me forward again
and once out in the more open space the
sense of terror diminished strangely
the winds were about and walking i
remember saying to myself
for the winds often move like great
presences under the trees
and altogether the fear that hovered
about me was such an unknown and immense
kind of fear
so unlike anything i had ever felt
before that it woke a sense of awe and
wonder in me
that did much to counteract its worst
effects and when i reached a high point
in the middle of the island from which i
could see the wide stretch of river
crimson and the sunrise the whole
magical beauty of it all was so
overpowering
that a sort of wild yearning woke in me
and almost brought a cry up into the
throat
but this cry found no expression for as
my eyes wandered from the plane beyond
to the island around me
and noted our little tent half hidden
among the willows
a dreadful discovery leaped out at me
compared to which my terror of the
walking winds seemed as nothing at all
for a change i thought had somehow come
about in the arrangement of the
landscape
it was not that my point of vantage gave
me a different view
but that an alteration had apparently
been affected in the relation of the
tent to the willows
and of the willows to the tent surely
the bushes now crowded much closer
unnecessarily unpleasantly close they
had moved
nearer creeping with silent feet over
the shifting sands
drawing imperceptibly nearer by soft
unhurried movements
the willows had come closer during the
night
but had the wind moved them or had they
moved of themselves
i recalled the sound of infinite small
patterns
and the pressure upon the tent and upon
my own heart that caused me to wake in
terror
i swayed for a moment in the wind like a
tree finding it hard to keep my upright
position
on the sandy hillock there was a
suggestion here of personal agency
of deliberate intention of aggressive
hostility
and it terrified me into a sort of
rigidity
then their reaction followed quickly the
idea was so bizarre
so absurd that i felt inclined to laugh
but the laughter came no more readily
than the cry for the knowledge that my
mind was so receptive to such dangerous
imaginings
brought the additional terror that it
was through our minds and not through
our physical bodies
that the attack would come and was
coming
the wind buffeted me about and very
quickly it seemed
the sun came up over the horizon for it
was after four o'clock
and i must have stood on that little
pinnacle of sand longer than i knew
afraid to come down to close quarters
with the willows
i returned quietly creepily to the tent
first taking another exhaustive look
round and
yes i confess it making a few
measurements
i paced out on the warm sand the
distances between the willows and the
tent
making a note of the shortest distance
particularly
i crawled stealthily into my blankets
my companion to all appearances still
slept soundly
and i was glad that this was so provided
my experiences were not corroborated
i could find strength somehow to deny
them perhaps
with the daylight i could persuade
myself that it was all a subjective
hallucination
a fantasy of the night a projection of
the excited imagination
nothing further came in to disturb me
and i fell asleep almost at once
utterly exhausted yet still in dread of
hearing again that weird sound of
multitudinous patterning
or of feeling the pressure upon my heart
that had made it difficult to breathe
the sun was high in the heavens when my
companion woke me from a heavy sleep
and announced that the porridge was
cooked and there was just time to bathe
the grateful smell of frizzling bacon
entered the tent door
river's still rising he said and several
islands out in mid-stream have
disappeared
altogether our own islands much smaller
any wood left i asked sleepily
the wood and the island will finish
tomorrow in a dead heat he laughed
but there's enough to last us till then
i plunged in from the point of the
island which had indeed altered a lot in
size and shape during the night
and was swept down in a moment to the
landing place opposite the tent
the water was icy and the banks flew by
like the country from an express train
bathing under such conditions was an
exhilarating operation
and the terror of the night seemed
cleansed out of me by a process of
evaporation in the brain
the sun was blazing hot not a cloud
showed itself anywhere
the wind however had not abated one
little jot
quite suddenly then the implied meaning
of the swede's words flashed across me
showing that he no longer wished to
leave post haste and had changed his
mind
enough to last till tomorrow he assumed
we should stay on the island another
night
it struck me as odd the night before he
was so positive the other way
how would the change come about great
crumblings of the banks occurred at
breakfast with heavy splashings and
clouds of spray which the wind brought
into our frying pan
and my fellow travelers hawked
incessantly about the difficulty the
vienna pest steamers must have
to find the channel in flood but the
state of his mind
interested and impressed me far more
than the state of the river or the
difficulties of the steamers
he had changed somehow since the evening
before
his manner was different a trifle
excited a trifle shy
with a sort of suspicion about his voice
and gestures
i hardly know how to describe it now in
cold blood
but at the time i remember being quite
certain of one thing
that he had become frightened he ate
very little
breakfast and for once admitted to smoke
his pipe
he had the map spread open beside him
and kept studying its markings
we'd better get off sharp in an hour i
said presently
feeling for an opening that must bring
him indirectly to a partial confession
at any rate
and his answer puzzled me uncomfortably
rather
if they'll let us who'll let us the
elements
i asked quickly with affected
indifference
the powers of this awful place whoever
they are
he replied keeping his eyes on the map
the gods are here if they are anywhere
at all in the world
the elements are always the true
immortals i replied
laughing as naturally as i could manage
yet knowing quite well that my face
reflected my true feelings when he
looked up
gravely at me and spoke across the smoke
we shall be fortunate if we get away
without further disaster
this was exactly what i had dreaded and
i screwed myself up to the point of the
direct question
it was like agreeing to allow the
dentist to extract the tooth
it had to come anyhow in the long run
and the rest was all pretense
further disaster why what's happened
for one thing the steering paddle's gone
he said quietly
the steering paddle gone i repeated
greatly excited
for this was our rudder and the danube
and flood without a rudder was suicide
but what and there's a tear in the
bottom of the canoe
he added with a genuine little tremor in
his voice
i continued staring at him able only to
repeat the words in his face somewhat
foolishly
there in the heat of the sun and on this
burning sand
i was aware of a freezing atmosphere
descending around us
i got up to follow him for he merely
nodded his head gravely
and led the way towards the tent a few
yards on the other side of the fireplace
the canoe still lay there as i had seen
her in the night
ribs uppermost the paddles or rather the
paddle
on the sand beside her there's only one
he said stooping to pick it up and
here's the rent in the baseboard
it was on the tip of my tongue to tell
him that i had clearly noticed two
paddles a few hours before
but a second impulse made me think
better of it and i said nothing
i approached to see there was a long
finely made tear in the bottom of the
canoe where a little slither of wood had
been neatly taken clean out
it looked as if the tooth of a sharp
rock or snag had eaten down her length
an investigation showed that the hole
went through
had we launched out in her without
observing it we must inevitably have
found her
at first the water would have made the
wood swell so as to close the hole
but one sounded midstream the water must
have poured in
and the canoe never more than two inches
above the surface
would have filled and sunk very rapidly
there you see an attempt to prepare a
victim for the sacrifice
i heard him saying more to himself than
to me
two victims rather he added as he bent
over and ran his fingers along the slit
i began to whistle a thing i always do
unconsciously when utterly non-plussed
and purposely paid no attention to his
words
i was determined to consider them
foolish
it wasn't there last night he said
presently
straightening up from his examination
and looking anywhere but at me
we must have scratched her in landing of
course i stopped whistling to say
the stones are very sharp i stopped
abruptly
for at that moment he turned round and
met my eye squarely
i knew just as well as he did how
impossible my explanation was there were
no stones to begin with
and then there's this to explain too he
added quietly
handing me the paddle and pointing to
the blade
a new and curious emotion spread
freezingly over me as i took and
examined it
the blade was scraped down all over
beautifully scraped
as though someone had sandpapered it
with care making it so
thin that the first vigorous stroke must
have snapped it off at the elbow
one of us walked in his sleep and did
this thing i said
feebly or or it's been filed by the
constant stream of sand particles blown
against it by the wind perhaps
ah said the swede turning away laughing
a little
you can explain everything the same wind
that caught the steering paddle and
flung it so near the bank that it fell
in with the next lump that crumbled
i called out after him absolutely
determined to find an explanation for
everything he showed me
i see he shouted back turning his head
to look at me before disappearing among
the willow bushes
once alone with these perplexing
evidences of personal agency
i think my first thoughts took the form
of one of us must have done this thing
and it certainly was not i
but my second thought decided how
impossible it was to suppose
under all the circumstances that either
of us had done it
that my companion the trusted friend of
a dozen similar expeditions
could have knowingly had a hand in it
was a suggestion not to be entertained
for a moment
equally absurd seemed the explanation
that this imperturbable and densely
practical nature
had suddenly become insane and was
busied with insane purposes
yet the fact remained that what
disturbed me most and kept my fear
actively alive even in this blaze of
sunshine and wild beauty was the clear
certainty that some curious alteration
had come about in his mind
that he was nervous timid suspicious
aware of goings-on he did not speak
about watching a series of secret and
hitherto unmentionable events
waiting in a word for a climax that he
expected
and i thought expected very soon this
grew up in my mind intuitively
i hardly knew how i made a hurried
examination of the tent in its
surroundings
but the measurements of the night remain
the same
there were deep hollows formed in the
sand i now noticed for the first time
basin shaped and of various depths and
sizes
varying from that of a teacup to a large
bowl
the wind no doubt was responsible for
these miniature craters
just as it was for lifting the paddle
and tossing it towards the water
the rent in the canoe was the only thing
that seemed quite inexplicable
and after all it was conceivable that a
sharp point had caught it when we landed
the examination i made of the shore did
not assist this theory
but all the same i clung to it with that
diminishing portion of my intelligence
which i called my reason
an explanation of some kind was an
absolute necessity
just as some working explanation of the
universe is necessary
however absurd to the happiness of every
individual who seeks to do his duty in
the world
and face the problems of life the simile
seemed to me at the time
an exact parallel i at once set the
pitch melting and presently the swede
joined me at the work
though under the best conditions in the
world the canoe could not be safe for
traveling till the following
day i drew his attention casually to the
hollows and the sand
yes he said i know they're all over the
island
but you can explain them no doubt wind
of course
i answered without hesitation have you
never watched those little whirlwinds in
the street that twist and twirl
everything into a circle
the sand's loose enough to yield that's
all
he made no reply and we worked on in
silence for a bit
i watched him surreptitiously all the
time and i had an idea he was watching
me
he seemed to to be always listening
attentively to something i could not
hear
or perhaps for something that he
expected to hear for he kept turning
about and staring into the bushes
and up into the sky and out across the
water where it was visible through the
openings among the willows
sometimes he even put his hand to his
ear and held it there for several
minutes
he said nothing to me however about it
and i asked no questions
and meanwhile as he mended that torn
canoe with the skill and address of a
red indian
i was glad to notice his absorption in
the work for there was a vague dread in
my heart that he would speak of the
changed aspect of the willows
and if he had noticed that my
imagination could no longer be held a
sufficient explanation of it
at length after a long pause he began to
talk
queer thing he added in a hurried sort
of voice
as though he wanted to say something and
get it over queer thing
i mean about that otter last night
i had expected something so totally
different that he caught me with
surprise
and i looked up sharply shows how lonely
this place is
otters are awfully shy things i don't
mean that of course
he interrupted i mean do you think
did you think it really was an otter
what else
in the name of heaven what else you know
i saw it before you did and at first it
seemed
so much bigger than an otter the sunset
as you looked upstream magnified it or
something
i replied he looked at me absently a
moment
as though his mind were busy with other
thoughts
it had such extraordinary yellow eyes he
went on half to himself
that was the sun too i laugh to trifle
boisterously
i suppose you'll wonder next if that
fellow in the boat
i suddenly decided not to finish the
sentence
he was in the act again of listening
turning his head to the wind
and something in the expression of his
face made me halt
the subject dropped and we went on with
our caulking
apparently he had not noticed my
unfinished sentence
five minutes later however he looked at
me across the canoe
the smoking pitch in his hand his face
exceedingly grave
i did rather wonder if you want to know
he said slowly
what that thing in the boat was i
remember thinking at the time it was not
a man
the whole business seemed to rise quite
suddenly out of the water
i laughed again boisterously in his face
but this time there was
impatience and a strain of anger too in
my feeling
look here now i cried this place is
quite queer enough without going out of
our way to imagine things
that boat was an ordinary boat and the
man in it was an ordinary man
and they were both going downstream as
fast as they could lick
and that otter was an otter so don't
let's play the fool about it
he looked steadily at me with the same
grave expression
he was not in the least annoyed i took
courage from his silence
and for heaven's sake i went on don't
keep pretending you hear things because
it only gives me the jumps
and there's nothing to hear but the
river and this cursed old thundering
wind
you fool he answered in a low shocked
voice
you utter fool that's just the way all
victims talk
as if you didn't understand just as well
as i do he sneered with scorn in his
voice
and a sort of resignation the best thing
you can do is keep quiet
and try to hold your mind as firm as
possible this feeble attempt at
self-deception only makes the truth
harder when you're forced to meet it
my little effort was over and i found
nothing more to say
for i knew quite well his words were
true and that i was the fool
not he up to a certain stage in the
adventure he kept ahead of me easily
and i think i felt annoyed to be out of
it to be thus proved less psychic
less sensitive than himself to these
extraordinary happenings
and half ignorant all the time of what
was going on under my very nose
he knew from the beginning apparently
but at the moment i wholly missed the
point of his words about the necessity
of there being a victim
and that we ourselves were destined to
satisfy the want
i dropped all pretense thenceforward but
then forward likewise my fear increased
steadily to
the climax but you're quite right about
one thing
he added before the subject passed and
that is that we're wiser not to talk
about it
or even to think about it because what
one thinks finds expression in words and
what one says
happens that afternoon while the canoe
dried and hardened
we spent trying to fish testing the leak
collecting wood
and watching the enormous flood of
rising water
masses of driftwood swept near our
shores sometimes
and we fished for them with long willow
branches
the island grew perceptibly smaller as
the banks were torn away with great
gulps and splashes
the weather kept brilliantly fine till
about four o'clock
and then for the first time in three
days the wind showed signs of abating
clouds began to gather in the southwest
spreading vents slowly over the sky
this lessening of the wind came as a
great relief for the incessant roaring
banging and thundering had irritated our
nerves
yet the silence that came about five
o'clock with its sudden cessation
was in a manner quite as oppressive the
booming of the river had everything in
its own way then it filled the air with
deep murmurs
more musical than the wind noises but
infinitely more monotonous
the wind held many notes rising falling
always beating out some sort of great
elemental tune
whereas the river's song lay between
three notes at most
dull petal notes that held a lugubrious
quality foreign to the wind
and somehow seemed to me in my then
nervous state
to sound wonderfully well the music of
doom
it was extraordinary too how the
withdrawal suddenly of bright sunlight
took
everything out of the landscape that
made for cheerfulness
and since this particular landscape had
already managed to convey the suggestion
of something sinister
the change of course was all the more
unwelcome and noticeable
for me i know the darkening outlook
became distinctly more alarming
and i found myself more than once
calculating how soon after sunset
the full moon would get up in the east
and whether the gathering clouds would
greatly interfere with her lighting of
the little island
with this general hush of the wind
though it still indulged in occasional
brief gusts
the river seemed to me to grow blacker
the willows to stand more densely
together
the latter too kept up a sort of
independent movement of their own
rustling among themselves when no wind
stirred and shaking oddly from the roots
upwards
when common objects in this way become
charged with the suggestion of horror
they stimulate the imagination far more
than things of unusual appearance
and these bushes crowding huddled about
us assumed for me in the darkness
a bizarre grotesquery of appearance that
lent to them somehow the aspect of
purposeful and living creatures
their very ordinariness i felt masked
what was malignant and hostile to us
the forces of the region drew nearer
with the coming of night
they were focusing upon our island and
more particularly upon ourselves
for thus somehow in the terms of the
imagination
did my really indescribable sensations
in this extraordinary place present
themselves
i had slept a good deal in the early
afternoon and had thus recovered
somewhat from the exhaustion of a
disturbed knight
but this only served apparently to
render me more susceptible than before
to the obsessing spell of the haunting i
fought against it
laughing at my feelings as absurd and
childish
with very obvious physiological
explanations
yet in spite of every effort they gained
in strength upon me
so that i dreaded the night as a child
lost in a forest must dread the approach
of darkness
the canoe we had carefully covered with
a waterproof sheet during the day
and the one remaining paddle had been
securely tied by the swede to the base
of a tree
lest the wind should rob us of that too
from five o'clock onwards i busied
myself with the stewpot and preparations
for dinner
it being my turn to cook that night we
had potatoes
onions bits of bacon fat to add flavor
and a general thick residue from former
stews at the bottom of the pot
with black bread broken up into it the
result was most
excellent and it was followed by a stew
of plums with sugar
and a brew of strong tea with dried milk
a good pile of wood lay close at hand
and the absence of wind made my duties
easy
my companion sat lazily watching me
dividing his attentions between cleaning
his pipe
and giving useless advice and admitted
privilege of the off-duty man
he had been very quiet all the afternoon
engaged in re-caulking the canoe
strengthening the tent ropes and fishing
for driftwood while i slept
no more talk about undesirable things
had passed between us
and i think his only remarks had to do
with the gradual destruction of the
island
which he declared was not fully a third
smaller than when we first landed
the pot had just begun to bubble when i
heard his voice calling me from the bank
where he had wandered away without my
noticing i ran up
come and listen he said and see what you
make of it
he held his hand cup wise to his ear as
so often before
now do you hear anything he asked
watching me curiously
we stood there listening attentively
together
at first i heard only the deep note of
the water and the hissings rising from
its turbulent surface
the willows for once were motionless and
silent
then a sound began to reach my ears
faintly a peculiar sound
something like the humming of a distant
gong
it seemed to come across to us in the
darkness from the waist of swamps and
willows opposite
it was repeated at regular intervals but
it was certainly neither the sound of a
bell
nor the hooting of a distant steamer i
can liken it to nothing so much as the
sound of an immense gong
suspended far up in the sky repeating
incessantly its muffled metallic note
soft and musical as it was repeatedly
struck
my heart quickened as i listened i've
heard it all day
said my companion while you slept this
afternoon
it came all around the island i hunted
it down but could never get near enough
to see
to localize it correctly sometimes it
was overhead
and sometimes it seemed under the water
once or twice too i could have sworn it
was not
outside at all but within myself you
know the way a sound in the fourth
dimension is supposed to come
i was too much puzzled to pay much
attention to his words
i listened carefully striving to
associate it with any known familiar
sound i could think of
but without success it changed in the
direction too
coming nearer and then sinking utterly
away into remote distance
i cannot say that it was ominous in
quality because to me it seemed
distinctly musical
yet i must admit it set going a
distressing feeling that made me wish i
had never heard it
the wind blowing in those sand funnels i
said
determined to find an explanation or the
bushes rubbing
together after the storm perhaps it
comes off the whole swamp
my friend answered it comes from
everywhere at once
he ignored my explanations it comes from
the willow bushes somehow
but now the wind has dropped i objected
the willows can hardly make a noise by
themselves can they
his answer frightened me first because i
had dreaded it
and secondly because i knew intuitively
it was true
it is because the wind has dropped we
now hear it it was drowned before
it is the cry i believe of the
i dashed back to my fire warned by the
sound of bubbling that the stew was in
danger
but determined at the same time to
escape further conversation
i was resolute if possible to avoid the
exchanging of views
i dreaded too that he would begin about
the gods or the elemental forces
or something else disquieting and i
wanted to keep myself well in hand for
what might happen later
there was another night to be faced
before we escaped from this distressing
place
and there was no knowing yet what it
might bring forth come and cut up bread
for the pot
i called to him vigorously stirring the
appetizing mixture
that stew pot held sanity for us both
and the thought made me laugh
he came over slowly and took the
provision sack from the tree
fumbling in its mysterious depths and
then emptying the entire contents upon
the ground sheet at his feet
hurry up i cried it's boiling
the swede burst out into a roar of
laughter that startled me
it was forced laughter not artificial
exactly but mirthless
there's nothing here he shouted holding
his sides
bread i mean it's gone there is no bread
they've taken it i dropped the long
spoon and ran
up everything the sack had contained lay
upon the ground sheet
but there was no loaf the whole dead
weight of my growing fear
fell upon me and shook me then i burst
out laughing too
it was the only thing to do and the
sound of my laughter also made me
understand his
the strain of psychical pressure caused
it this explosion of
unnatural laughter in both of us it was
an effort of repressed forces to seek
relief
it was a temporary safety valve and with
both of us it ceased quite suddenly
how criminally stupid of me i cried
still determined to be consistent
and find an explanation i clean forgot
to buy a loaf at pressburg
that chattering woman put everything out
of my head and i must have left it lying
on the counter or
the oatmeal too is much less than it was
this morning
the swede interrupted why in the world
need he draw attention to it
i thought angrily there's enough for
tomorrow
i said stirring vigorously and we can
get lots more at comorn or gran
in 24 hours we shall be miles from here
i hope so to god he muttered putting the
things back into the sack
unless we're claimed first as victims
for the sacrifice
he added with a foolish laugh he dragged
the sack into the tent
for safety's sake i suppose and i heard
him mumbling to himself
but so indistinctly that it seemed quite
natural for me to ignore his words
our meal was beyond question a gloomy
one and we ate it almost in silence
avoiding one another's eyes and keeping
the fire bright
then we washed up and prepared for the
night and once smoking
our minds unoccupied with any definite
duties the apprehension i had felt all
day long became more and more acute
it was not then active fear i think but
the very vagueness of its origin
distressed me far more
than if i had been able to tick it and
face it squarely
the curious sound i have likened to the
note of a gong became now almost
incessant
and filled the stillness of the night
with a faint continuous ringing
rather than a series of distinct notes
at one time it was behind
and at another time in front of us
sometimes i fancied it came from the
bushes on our left
and then again from the clumps on our
right more often it hovered directly
overhead
like the whirring of wings it was really
everywhere at once
behind in front at our sides and over
our heads
completely surrounding us the sound
really defies description
but nothing within my knowledge is like
that ceaseless muffled humming
rising off the deserted world of swamps
and willows
we sat smoking in comparative silence
the strain growing
every minute greater the worst feature
of the situation
seemed to me that we did not know what
to expect and could therefore make no
sort of preparation by way of defense
we could anticipate nothing my
explanations made in the sunshine
moreover
now came to haunt me with their foolish
and wholly unsatisfactory nature
and it was more and more clear to us
that some kind of plain talk with my
companion was inevitable
whether i liked it or not after all we
had to spend the night together
and to sleep in the same tent side by
side
i saw that i could not get along much
longer without the support of his mind
and for that of course plain talk was
imperative
as long as possible however i postponed
this little climax
and tried to ignore or laugh at the
occasional sentences he flung into the
emptiness
some of these sentences moreover were
confoundedly disquieting to me
coming as they did to corroborate much
that i felt myself
corroboration too which made it so much
more convincing
from a totally different point of view
he composed such curious sentences
and hurled them at me in such an
inconsequential sort of way
as though his main line of thought was
secret to himself and these fragments
were mere bits he found it impossible to
digest
he got rid of them by uttering them
speech relieved him
it was like being sick there are things
about us
i'm sure that make for disorder
disintegration
destruction our destruction he said once
while the fire blazed between us we've
strayed out of a safe line somewhere
and another time when the gong sounds
had come nearer
ringing much louder than before and
directly over our heads
he said as though talking to himself i
don't think a gramophone would show any
record of that
the sound doesn't come to me by the ears
at all the vibrations reach me in
another manner altogether
and seem to be within me which is
precisely how a fourth dimensional sound
might be supposed to make itself heard
i purposely made no reply to this but i
sat up a little closer to the
fire and peered about me into the
darkness
the clouds were masked all over the sky
and no trace of moonlight came through
very still too everything was so that
the river and the frogs had things all
their own way
it has that about it he went on which is
utterly out of common experience
it is unknown only one thing describes
it really
it is a non-human sound i mean a sound
outside humanity
having rid himself of this indigestible
morsel he lay quiet for a time
but he had so admirably expressed my own
feeling that it was a relief to have the
thought out
and to have confined it by the
limitation of words from dangerous
wandering to and fro in the mind
the solitude of that danube camping
place can i ever forget it
the feeling of being utterly alone on an
empty planet
my thoughts ran incessantly upon cities
and the haunts of men
i would have given my soul as the saying
is for the feel of those bavarian
villages we had passed through by the
score
for the normal human commonplaces
peasants drinking beer
tables beneath the trees hot sunshine
and a ruined castle on the rocks behind
the red reef church
even the tourists would have been
welcome yet what i felt of dread was no
ordinary ghostly fear
it was infinitely greater stranger and
seemed to arise from some dim ancestral
sense of terror more profoundly
disturbing than anything i had known or
dreamed of
we had strayed as the swede put it into
some region
or some set of conditions where the
risks were great yet unintelligible to
us
where the frontiers of some unknown
world lay close about us
it was a spot held by the dwellers in
some outer space
a sort of peephole once they could spy
upon the earth themselves unseen a point
where the veil between had worn a little
fin
as the final result of too long a
sojourn here we should be carried over
the border
and deprived of what we called our lives
yet by mental not
physical processes in that sense as he
said
we should be the victims of our
adventure a sacrifice
it took us in different fashion each
according to the measure of his
sensitiveness and powers of resistance
i translated it vaguely into a
personification of the mightily
disturbed elements
investing them with the horror of a
deliberate and malefic purpose
resentful of our audacious intrusion
into their breeding place
whereas my friend threw it into the
unoriginal form at first of a trespass
on some ancient shrine
some place where the old gods still held
sway where the emotional forces of
former worshippers still clung
and the ancestral portion of him yielded
to the old pagan spell
at any rate here was a place unpolluted
by men
kept clean by the winds from coarsening
human influences
a place where spiritual agencies were
within reach and aggressive
never before or since have i been so
attacked by
indescribable suggestions of a beyond
region
of another scheme of life another
revolution not parallel to the human
and in the end our minds would succumb
under the weight of the awful spell
and we should be drawn across the
frontier into their world
small things testified to the amazing
influence of the place
and now in the silence around the fire
they allowed themselves to be noted by
the mind
the very atmosphere had proved itself a
magnifying medium to distort every
indication
the otter rolling in the current the
hurrying boatmen making signs
the shifting willows one and all had
been robbed of its natural character
and revealed in something of its other
aspect as it existed across the border
to that other region
and this changed aspect i felt was now
not merely to me
but to the race the whole experience
whose verge we touched was unknown to
humanity at all
it was a new order of experience and in
the true sense of the word
unearthly it's the deliberate
calculating purpose that reduces one's
courage to zero
the swede said suddenly as if he had
been actually following my thoughts
otherwise imagination might count for
much but the paddle
the canoe the lessening food haven't i
explained all that once
i interrupted viciously you have he
answered dryly
you have indeed he made other remarks
too as usual
about what he called the plain
determination to provide a victim
but having now arranged my thoughts
better i recognized that this was simply
the cry of his frightened soul
against the knowledge that he was being
attacked in a vital part
and that he would be somehow taken or
destroyed the situation called for a
courage and calmness of reasoning that
neither of us could compass
and i have never before been so clearly
conscious of two persons in me
the one that explained everything and
the other that laughed at such foolish
explanations
yet was horribly afraid meanwhile
in the pitchy night the fire died down
and the wood pile grew small
neither of us moved to replenish the
stock and the darkness consequently came
up very close to our faces
a few feet beyond the circle of
firelight it was inky black
occasionally a stray puff of wind set
the willows shivering about us
but apart from this not very welcome
sound a deep and depressing silence
reigned
broken only by the gurgling of the river
and the humming in the air overhead
we both missed i think the shouting
company of the winds
at length at a moment when a stray puff
prolonged itself as though the wind were
about to rise again
i reached the point for me of saturation
the point where it was absolutely
necessary to find relief in plain speech
or else to betray myself by some
hysterical extravagance
that must have been far worse than its
effect upon both of us
i kicked the fire into a blaze and
turned to my companion abruptly
he looked up with a start i can't
disguise it any longer
i said i don't like this place and the
darkness and the noises and the awful
feelings i get
there's something here that beats me
utterly i'm in a blue funk and that's
the plain truth
if the other shore was different i swear
i'd be inclined to swim for it
the swede's face turned very white
beneath the deep tan of sun and wind
he stared straight at me and answered
quietly but his voice betrayed his huge
excitement by its unnatural calmness
for the moment at any rate he was the
strong man of the two
he was more phlegmatic for one thing
it's not a physical condition we can
escape from by running away
he replied in the tone of a doctor
diagnosing some grave disease
we must sit tight and wait there are
forces close here that could kill a herd
of elephants in a second
as easily as you or i could squash a fly
our only chance is to keep perfectly
still
our insignificance perhaps may save us
i put a dozen questions into my
expression of face
but found no words it was precisely like
listening to an accurate description of
a disease whose symptoms had puzzled me
i mean that so far although aware of our
disturbing presence
they have not found us not located us as
the americans say
he went on they're blundering about like
men hunting for a leak of gas
the paddle and canoe and provisions
prove that
i think they feel us but cannot actually
see us
we must keep our minds quiet it's our
minds they feel
we must control our thoughts or it's all
up with us
death you mean i stammered icy with the
horror of his suggestion
worse by far he said
death according to one's belief means
either annihilation
or release from the limitations of the
senses but it involves no change of
character
you don't suddenly alter just because
the body's gone
but this means a radical alteration a
complete change
a horrible loss of oneself by
substitution
far worse than death and not even
annihilation
we happen to have camped in a spot where
their region touches ours
where the veil between has worn thin
horrors he was using my very own phrase
my actual words
so that they are aware of our being in
their neighborhood
but who are aware i asked i forgot the
shaking of the willows and the windless
calm
the humming overhead everything except
that i was waiting for an answer that i
dreaded more than i can possibly explain
he lowered his voice at once to reply
leaning forward a little over the fire
an indefinable change in his face that
made me avoid his eyes and looked down
upon the ground
all my life he said i have been
strangely
vividly conscious of another region not
far removed from our own world in one
sense
yet wholly different and kind where
great things go on unceasingly
where immense and terrible personalities
hurry by
intent on vast purposes compared to
which earthly affairs
the rise and fall of nations the
destinies of empires
the fate of armies and continents are
all as dust in the balance
vast purposes i mean that deal directly
with the soul
and not indirectly with more expressions
of the soul
i suggest just now i began seeking to
stop him
feeling as though i was face to face
with a madman but he instantly overbore
me with his torrent that had to come
you think he said it is the spirit of
the elements
and i thought perhaps it was the old
gods but i tell you now it is
neither these would be comprehensible
entities
for they have relations with men
depending upon them for worship or
sacrifice
whereas these beings who are now about
us have absolutely nothing to do with
mankind
and it is mere chance that their space
happens just at this spot
to touch our own the mere conception
which his words somehow made so
convincing as i listened to them there
in the dark stillness of that lonely
island
set me shaking a little all over i found
it impossible to control my movements
and what do you propose i began again
a sacrifice a victim might save us by
distracting them until we could get away
he went on just as the wolves stopped to
devour the dogs and give the sleigh
another start
but i see no chance of any other victim
now
i stared blankly at him the gleam in his
eye was dreadful
presently he continued
it's the willows of course the willows
mask the others
but the others are feeling about for us
if we let our minds betray our fear
we're lost
lost utterly he looked at me with an
expression
so calm so determined so sincere
that i no longer had any doubts as to
his sanity
he was as sane as any man ever was
if we can hold out through the night he
added we may get off in the daylight
unnoticed
or rather undiscovered but you really
think a sacrifice would
that gong like humming came down very
close over our heads as i spoke
but it was my friend's scared face that
really stopped my mouth
hush he whispered holding up his hand do
not mention them more than you can help
do not refer to them by name to name is
to reveal
it is the inevitable clue and our only
hope lies in ignoring them
in order that they may ignore us even in
thought
he was extraordinarily agitated
especially in thought
our thoughts make spirals in their world
we must keep them out of our minds at
all costs if possible
i raked the fire together to prevent the
darkness having everything its own way
i never longed for the sun as i longed
for it then in the awful blackness of
that summer night
were you awake all last night he went on
suddenly
i slept badly a little after dawn i
replied evasively
trying to follow his instructions which
i knew instinctively were true
but the wind of course i know
but the wind won't account for all the
noises
then you heard it too the multiplying
countless little footsteps i heard
he said adding after a moment's
hesitation and that other sound
you mean above the tent and the pressing
down upon us of something tremendous
gigantic he nodded significantly
it was like the beginning of a sort of
inner suffocation
i said partly yes
it seemed to me that the weight of the
atmosphere had been altered
had increased enormously so that we
should have been crushed
and that i went on determined to have it
all out
pointing upwards where the gong-like
note hummed ceaselessly
rising and falling like wind what do you
make of that
it's their sound he whispered gravely
it's the sound of their world
the humming in their region the division
here is so
thin that it leaks through somehow but
if you listen carefully
you'll find it's not above so much as
around us
it's in the willows it's the willows
themselves humming
because here the willows have been made
symbols of the forces that are against
us i could not follow exactly what he
meant by this
yet the thought and idea in my mind were
beyond question the thought and idea in
his
i realized what he realized only with
less power of analysis than his
it was on the tip of my tongue to tell
him at last about my hallucination of
the ascending figures and the moving
bushes
when he suddenly thrust his face again
close into mine across the firelight
and began to speak in a very earnest
whisper he amazed me by his calmness and
pluck
his apparent control of the situation
this man i had for years deemed
unimaginative solid
now listen he said the only thing for us
to do is to go on as though nothing had
happened
follow our usual habits go to bed and so
forth
pretend we feel nothing and notice
nothing
it is a question holy of the mind and
the less we think about them
the better our chance of escape above
all don't think
for what you think happens all right
i managed to reply simply breathless
with his words and the strangeness of it
all
all right i'll try but tell me one more
thing first
tell me what you make of those hollows
in the ground all about us
those sand funnels no he cried
forgetting to whisper in his excitement
i dare not i simply dare not put the
thought into words
if you have not guessed i am glad don't
try to
they have put it into my mind try your
hardest to prevent their putting it into
yours
he sank his voice again to a whisper
before he finished and i did not press
him to explain
there was already just about as much
horror in me as i could hold
the conversation came to an end and we
smoked our pipes busily in silence
then something happened something
unimportant apparently
as the way is when the nerves are in a
very great state of tension
and this small thing for a brief space
gave me an entirely different point of
view
i chanced to look down at my sand shoe
the sort we used for the canoe
and something to do with the hole at the
toe suddenly recalled to me the london
shop where i had bought them
the difficulty the man had in fitting me
and other details of the uninteresting
but practical operation
at once in its train followed a
wholesome view of the modern skeptical
world i was accustomed to move in at
home
i thought of roast beef and ale motor
cars
policemen brass bands and a dozen other
things that proclaimed the soul of
ordinariness or utility
the effect was immediate and astonishing
even to myself
psychologically i suppose it was simply
a sudden and violent reaction after the
strain of living in an atmosphere of
things that to the normal consciousness
must seem impossible and incredible but
whatever the cause it momentarily lifted
the spell from my heart
and left me for the short space of a
minute feeling free and utterly unafraid
i looked up at my friend opposite you
damned old pagan i cried laughing aloud
on his face
you imaginative idiot you superstitious
idolater
you i stopped in the middle seized anew
by the old horror
i tried to smother the sound of my voice
as something sacrilegious
the swede of course heard it too the
strange cry overhead in the darkness
and that sudden drop in the air as
though something had come nearer
he had turned ashen white under the tan
he stood bolt upright in front of the
fire
stiff as a rod staring at me after that
he said in a sort of helpless frantic
way we must go
we can't stay now we must strike camp
this very instant and go on
down the river he was talking i saw
quite wildly his words dictated by
abject terror
the terror he had resisted so long but
which had caught him at last
in the dark i exclaimed shaking with
fear after my hysterical outburst
but still realizing our position better
than he did
sheer madness the river's in flood and
we've only got a single paddle
besides we only go deeper into their
country there's nothing ahead for 50
miles but willows willows willows
he sat down again in a state of
semi-collapse
the positions by one of those
kaleidoscopic changes nature loves
were suddenly reversed and the control
of our forces passed over into my hands
his mind at last had reached the point
where it was beginning to weaken
what on earth possessed you to do such a
thing he whispered with the awe of
genuine terror in his voice and face
i crossed round to his side of the fire
i took both his hands and mine
kneeling down beside him and looking
straight into his frightened eyes
we'll make one more blaze i said firmly
and then turn in for the night
at sunrise we'll be off full speed for
comorn
now pull yourself together a bit and
remember your own advice about not
thinking fear
he said no more and i saw that he would
agree and obey
in some measure two it was a sort of
relief to get up and make an excursion
into the darkness for more wood
we kept close together almost touching
groping among the bushes and along the
bank
the humming overhead never ceased but
seemed to me to grow louder as we
increased our distance from the fire
it was shivery work we were grubbing
away
in the middle of a thickish clump of
willows where some driftwood from a
former flood had caught high among the
branches
when my body was seized in a grip that
made me half drop upon the sand
it was the swede he had fallen against
me and was clutching me for support
i heard his breath coming and going in
short gasps
look by my soul he whispered and for the
first time in my experience i knew what
it was to hear tears of terror and a
human voice
he was pointing to the fire some fifty
feet away
i followed the direction of his finger
and i swear my heart missed a beat
there in front of the dim glow something
was moving
i saw it through a veil that hung before
my eyes like the gauze drop curtain used
at the back of a theater
hazily a little it was neither a human
figure
nor an animal to me it gave the strange
impression of being as large as several
animals grouped together like horses
two or three moving slowly the swede too
got a similar result
though expressing it differently for he
thought it was shaped and sized like a
clump of willow bushes
rounded at the top and moving all over
upon its surface
coiling upon itself like smoke he said
afterwards
i watched it settle downwards through
the bushes he sobbed at me
look by god it's coming this way oh
oh he gave a kind of whistling cry they
found us
i gave one terrified glance which just
enabled me to see that the shadowy form
was swinging towards us through the
bushes
and then i collapsed backwards with a
crash into the branches
these failed of course to support my
weight so that with the swede on top of
me we fell in a struggling heap upon the
sand
i really hardly knew what was happening
i was conscious only of a sort of
enveloping sensation of icy fear that
plucked the nerves out of their fleshy
covering
twisted them this way and that and
replaced them quivering
my eyes were tightly shut something in
my throat choked me
a feeling that my consciousness was
expanding extending out into space
swiftly gave way to another feeling that
i was losing it altogether
and about to die an acute spasm of pain
passed through me and i was aware that
the swede had hold of me in such a way
that he hurt me abominably
it was the way he caught at me and
falling but it was the pain he declared
afterwards that saved me
it caused me to forget them and think of
something else at the very instant when
they were about to find me
it concealed my mind from them at the
moment of discovery
yet just in time to evade their terrible
seizing of me
he himself he says actually swooned at
the same moment
and that was what saved him i only know
that at a later date
how long or short is impossible to say i
found myself scrambling up out of the
slippery network of willow branches
and saw my companion standing in front
of me holding out a hand to assist me
i stared at him in a dazed way rubbing
the arm he had twisted for me
nothing came to me to say somehow
i lost consciousness for a moment or two
i heard him say
that's what saved me it made me stop
thinking about them
you nearly broke my arm into i said
uttering my only connected thought at
the moment
a numbness came over me that's what
saved you
he replied between us we've managed to
set them off on a false tack somewhere
the humming is ceased it's gone for the
moment at any rate
a wave of hysterical laughter seized me
again and this time spread to my friend
too
great healing gusts of shaking laughter
that brought a tremendous sense of
relief in their train
we made our way back to the fire and put
the wood on so that it blazed at once
then we saw that the tent had fallen
over and lay in a tangled heap upon the
ground
we picked it up and during the process
tripped more than once and caught our
feet in the sand
it's those sand funnels exclaimed the
swede when the tent was up again and the
fire light lit up the ground for several
yards about us
and look at the size of them all around
the tent and about the fireplace where
we had seen the moving shadows there
were deep funnel-shaped hollows in the
sand
exactly similar to the ones we had
already found over the island
only far bigger and deeper beautifully
formed
and wide enough in some instances to
admit the whole of my foot and leg
neither of us said a word we both knew
that sleep was the safest thing we could
do
and to bed we went accordingly without
further delay
having first thrown sand on the fire and
taken the provision sack and the paddle
inside the tent with us
the canoe too we propped in such a way
at the end of the tent that our feet
touched it
and the least motion would disturb and
wake us
in case of emergency too we again went
to bed in our clothes
ready for a sudden start it was my firm
intention to lie awake all night and
watch
but the exhaustion of nerves and body
decreed otherwise
and sleep after a while came over me
with a welcome blanket of oblivion
the fact that my companion also slept
quickened its approach
at first he fidgeted and constantly sat
up asking me if i heard this
or heard that he tossed about on his
cork mattress
and said the tent was moving and the
river had risen over the point of the
island
but each time i went out to look i
returned with the report that all was
well
and finally he grew calmer and lay still
then at length his breathing became
regular and i heard unmistakable sounds
of snoring
the first and only time in my life when
snoring has been a welcome and calming
influence
this i remember was the last thought in
my mind before dozing off
a difficulty in breathing woke me and i
found the blanket over my face
but something else besides the blanket
was pressing upon me
and my first thought was that my
companion had rolled off his mattress
onto my own in his sleep
i called to him and sat up and at the
same moment it came to me that the tent
was surrounded
that sound of multitudinous soft
patterning was again audible outside
filling the knight with horror
i called again to him louder than before
he did not answer
but i missed the sound of his snoring
and also noticed that the flap of the
tent was down
this was the unpardonable sin i crawled
out in the darkness to hook it back
securely
and it was then for the first time i
realized positively that the swede was
not here
he had gone i dashed out in a mad run
seized by a dreadful agitation and the
moment i was out i plunged into a sort
of torrent of humming
that surrounded me completely and came
out of every quarter of the heavens at
once
it was that same familiar humming gone
mad
a swarm of great invisible bees might
have been about me in the air
the sound seemed to thicken the very
atmosphere and i felt that my lungs
worked with difficulty
but my friend was in danger and i could
not hesitate
the dawn was just about to break and a
faint whitish light spread upwards over
the clouds from a thin
strip of clear horizon no wind stirred
i could just make out the bushes and
river beyond and the pale sandy patches
in my excitement i ran frantically to
and fro about the island
calling him by name shouting at the top
of my voice the first words that came
into my head
but the willows smothered my voice and
the humming muffled it
so that the sound only traveled a few
feet round me
i plunged among the bushes tripping
headlong tumbling over roots
and scraping my face as i tore this way
in that among the preventing branches
then quite unexpectedly i came out upon
the island's point
and saw a dark figure outlined between
the water and the sky
it was the swede and already he had one
foot in the river
a moment more and he would have taken
the plunge
i threw myself upon him flinging my arms
about his waist and dragging him
shorewards with all my strength
of course he struggled furiously making
a noise all the time just like that
cursed humming
and using the most outlandish phrases in
his anger about going inside to them
and taking the way of the water in the
wind and god only knows what more
besides
that i tried in vain to recall
afterwards but which turned me sick with
horror and amazement as i listened
but in the end i managed to get him into
the comparative safety of the tent
and flung him breathless and cursing
upon the mattress where i held him until
the fit had passed
i think the suddenness with which it all
went and he grew calm
coinciding as it did with the equally
abrupt cessation of the humming and
patterning outside
i think this was almost the strangest
part of the whole business perhaps
for he had just opened his eyes and
turned his tired face up to me
so that the dawn threw a pale light upon
it through the doorway
and said for all the world just like a
frightened child
my life old man it's my life i owe you
but it's all over now anyhow
they found a victim in our place then he
dropped back upon his blankets and went
to sleep literally under my eyes
he simply collapsed and began to snore
again as healthfully as though nothing
had happened
and he had never tried to offer his own
life as a sacrifice by drowning
and when the sunlight woke him three
hours later hours of ceaseless vigil for
me
it became so clear to me that he
remembered absolutely nothing of what he
had attempted to do
that i deemed it wise to hold my peace
and ask no dangerous questions
he woke naturally and easily as i have
said when the sun was already high in a
windless hot sky
and he at once got up and set about the
preparation of the fire for breakfast
i followed him anxiously at bathing but
he did not attempt to plunge in
merely dipping his head and making some
remark about the extra coldness of the
water
rivers falling at last he said and i'm
glad of it
the humming is stopped too i said
he looked up at me quietly with his
normal expression
evidently he remembered everything
except his own attempt at suicide
everything is stopped he said because
he hesitated but i knew some reference
to that remark he had made just before
he fainted was in his mind
and i was determined to know it because
they found another victim
i said forcing a little laugh exactly
he answered exactly i feel as positive
of it as though
as though i feel quite safe again i mean
he finished
he began to look curiously about him the
sunlight lay in hot patches on the sand
there was no wind the willows were
motionless
he slowly rose to his feet come he said
i think if we look we shall find it he
started off on a run and i followed him
he kept to the banks poking with a stick
among the sandy bays and caves and
little backwaters
myself always close on his heels ah
he exclaimed presently ah
the tone of his voice somehow brought
back to me a vivid sense of the horror
of the last
24 hours and i hurried up to join him
he was pointing with a stick at a large
black object that lay half in the water
and half on the sand
it appeared to be caught by some twisted
willow roots so that the river could not
sweep it away
a few hours before the spot must have
been underwater
see he said quietly the victim that made
our escape possible
and when i peered across his shoulder i
saw that his stick rested on the body of
a man
he turned it over it was the corpse of a
peasant
and the face was hidden in the sand
clearly the man had been drowned
but a few hours before and his body must
have been swept down upon our island
somewhere about the hour of the dawn
at the very time the fit had passed
we must give it a decent burial you know
i suppose so i replied i shuddered a
little in spite of myself
for there was something about the
appearance of that poor drowned man that
turned me cold
the swede glanced up sharply at me an
undecipherable expression on his face
and began clambering down the bank i
followed him more leisurely
the current i noticed had torn away much
of the clothing from the body
so that the neck and part of the chest
lay bare
halfway down the bank my companion
suddenly stopped and held up his hand in
warning
but either my foot slipped or i had
gained too much momentum to bring myself
quickly to a halt for i bumped into him
and sent him forward with a sort of leap
to save myself
we tumbled together onto the hard sand
so that our feet splashed into the water
and before anything could be done we had
collided a little heavily
against the corpse the swede uttered a
sharp cry
and i sprang back as if i had been shot
at the moment we touched the body there
rose from its surface the loud sound of
humming
the sound of several hummings which
passed with a vast commotion as of
winged things in the air about us
and disappeared upwards into the sky
growing fainter and fainter until they
finally ceased in the distance
it was exactly as though we had
disturbed some living yet invisible
creatures at work
my companion clutched me and i think i
clutched him
but before either of us had time
properly to recover from the unexpected
shock
we saw that a movement of the current
was turning the corpse round
so that it became released from the grip
of the willow roots
a moment later it had turned completely
over the dead face uppermost
staring at the sky it lay on the edge of
the mainstream
in another moment it would be swept away
the swede started to save it shouting
again something i did not catch about a
proper burial
and then abruptly dropped upon his knees
on the sand and covered his eyes with
his hands
i was beside him in an instant i saw
what he had seen
for just as the body swung round to the
current the face and the exposed chest
turned full towards us
and showed plainly how the skin and
flesh were indented with small hollows
beautifully formed and exactly similar
in shape and kind
to the sand funnels that we had found
all over the island
their mark i heard my companion mutter
under his breath
their awful mark and when i turned my
eyes again from his ghastly face to the
river
the current had done its work and the
body had been swept away into mid-stream
and was already beyond our reach and
almost out of sight
turning over and over on the waves like
an otter
you